t'as le bonjour casimir à bonjour
françois ohlala tu m'as l'air bien
fatigué non non je pense à ça alors est
dû pour sa cour mais rien ce pas trop
fatiguant pas au contraire c'est très
difficile bon je te laisse mais ne te
fatigue pas trop j'ai c'est un bon jour
je les salue françois
qu'est ce qui arriva casimir je ne sais
pas très bien et cela fait un long
moment qu'il est là comme ça ils
essaient de ne penser à rien c'est ce
qu'il me dise il veut oublier oublié
mais quoi je ne sais pas j'ai cru
comprendre qu'il ne se sentait pas assez
utile tu sais qu'il faudrait lui faire
faire quelque chose avait écouté une
idée il faut que j'aille un rendez vous
je comptais te demander de me garder mes
balles au jeu pourrait le lui demander à
lui ramener c'est une excellente idée du
jeu train un coup d'oeil de temps en
temps c'est un fait quasi mission
courtois et que ces droits casimir nerfs
je voulais te demander de me rendre
service
quand un vrai service important très
important mais françois j'adore hommes
des services
on ne m'en demande jamais je trouve que
tu exagères casimir tu fais beaucoup de
choses utiles dans l'île aux enfants
en tout cas aujourd'hui je voudrais que
tu t'occupes de mes ballerines accord je
les garde boue je les vends situe peut
engendrer ou deux ce sera formidable
bien je vais inventer une idée géniale
et je les vendrais tout ça tranchante
casimir je préfère que d'une agente
aucune idée géniale
si durant un ou deux ce sera déjà très
bien
bon je vois monsieur n'a pas confiance
en moi monsieur se méfie très bien gens
retournent penser mais câline
françois houtart y indique désagréable
enfin et a simplement demandé de vendre
ses ballons comme il le fait lui-même
bon alors c'est d'accord
parfait je vais à mon rendez vous
surveillez le quand même je ne suis pas
très rassuré ne t'inquiète pas je m'en
occupe
non mais les ballons enchères est
vraiment bon ballon ballon par ici les
ballots qu'est ce que c'est mais enfin
c'est pas du tout le style de l'île aux
enfants qu'est ce qui n'est pas le style
de l'île aux enfants leur fait de crier
comme ça à la cantonade alloue à bon bon
ben excuse moi je me suis trompé
sûrement quel dommage alors qu'est ce
que je pourrais bien faire pour arriver
avant dans ces ballons mais qu'est ce
qui t'arrive casimir tu parle tout seul
maintenant non oui enfin je disais que
j'aimerais bien vendre un ballon et
casimir est un peu de patience ça fait
deux minutes que tu installes et tu sais
avec tous les enfants qui lie à dans
l'île tu n'as pas de souci à ce faire tu
voudras beaucoup de ballons tu crois
certainement mais qu'est ce que je
pourrais bien faire pour vendre ses
ballons ils sont pourtant jolie julie et
skiant que c'est six mois j'étais un
enfant et bien j'achèterai beaucoup
ballon wils allemand c'est toi qui les
vaut ben oui il faudrait vraiment que je
trouve une méthode génial écoute casimir
pour te remonter le moral et pour tout
pour tes chances c'est moi qui vais te
lâcheté ton premier ballon merci j à
alors lequel vulture garde le bleu le
jaune le rouge le vert les jaunes à ça
arrive à faire bien sûr mon casque à
combien je te dois apprend c'est pas
cher aux non pas du tout pour un aussi
joli ballon bon ben je retourne à mon
casque bon courage merci julie
il faut que je trouve une idée
formidable avec ma malle magique
j'ai une solution je vais trouver un
carton et un stylo et je vais écrire à
une pancarte
voilà sur l'île aux enfants vente de
ballons unique au monde
occasion à ne pas manquer voilà parfait
en battant pas montanou par une patte à
manta pas contents ils parlent
et tiens ça allait on aller pour casimir
bon lequel choisir le rouge ça se verra
mieux voilà
voilà vente unique au monde
très bien ammouta tam tam tam tam tam
tam papa me tend papam pas vous plaindre
casimir ouais ça va oui ça va je monte
la garde devant mes balles au papa maman
papa vous me portant une pancarte en
désignant ouais tu cherche quelqu'un oui
j'attends un client a bon parfois
j'allais oublier le principal mon feutre
pour faire les dessins auxquels désordre
là dedans ah voilà voilà
mais enfin casimir est un peu auprès de
thé ballon tu tapes semble tout le temps
tu n'entendras jamais tu as raison j'y
vais comment sont les dessins voilà que
c'était vraiment très beau ça ah oui qui
sont vraiment des ballons minique au
monde
casimir qu'est-ce que ça ça va tu tiens
le coup oui ça va très bien oui mon gars
voici un client mais c'est monsieur 10 9
11 notre chers amis bonjour mais ces
jeunes ont donc azimi bonjour mathieu
des saunas bienvenue de honey de moi mon
cher ami je suis très pressé voulait pas
vu françois mais il était un rendez vous
mais il m'a il ne va pas tarder à
revenir nous pouvons lui faire une
commission si vous voulez c'est à dire
que c'est bien ici qu'il ya aujourd'hui
une vente exceptionnelle de ballon
unique au monde une occasion à ne pas
manquer c'est pas quasiment
et enfin julich monsieur du snav venez
c'est par là c'est ici lors d'une vente
oui ou non
et bien c'est à dire oui il y avait une
vente malheureusement j'ai presque tout
vendu
il me reste plus que 11 11 7 13 ans b
dont à casimir je suis venu tout exprès
enfin montré deux mois quand même les
voir si splendides n'est ce pas trop
mais c'est mon portrait et oui oui vous
savez ce sont les derniers et j'y tiens
vraiment beaucoup
mais si vous voulez pour vous je veux
bien vous les laisser à 10 francs sur
mes yeux ce blé de transcendantal
extraordinaire mais j'achète alors 10
francs pièce mais n'en parler à personne
on en est ou non une 10 francs pièce ça
fait eu quatre ou cinq ans 70 80 90 ce
sont 110 contrats mais sans écran oui ça
fait longtemps d'accord alors voilà
trente 30 60 euros
et puis attendre
vincent dix ans voilà merci à monsieur
le 110 par des chaloupes le pourboire
bon merci beaucoup qui signa attendez
vous partez s'en fout pas long à oui
c'est vrai merci répond que c'est mieux
pour toi
au revoir ma très chère amy je vous
laisse je vais exposer ce petit
chef-d'oeuvre grand salan avoir reçu dix
neuf
julie ça y est j'ai tout vendu avant
casimir voilà l'argent ça fait 100
francs sans on se rend pour tous ballon
mais tu les as vendu beaucoup plus cher
que françois non je ne pouvais pas les
vendre au prix normal à monsieur du snav
pourquoi pourquoi j'avais dessiné son
portrait dessus si je l'avais vendu son
portrait à 1 franc pièce il aura été
furieux et vexée d'avoir son portrait
pour un prix aussi bas
casimir
[Musique]